and as promised here he is entering
season number eight is the general
manager of the jacksonville jaguars he
is
dave caldwell david welcome back how are
you pal thanks for having me i'm i'm
doing great and yourself i'm doing great
i learned something about you today
doing a little research you went to the
same school as don chula john carroll
and also
john carroll is like a hotbed of nfl
figures how in the hell did it happen
that so many people connected to the nfl
ended up with john carroll well i think
you have to start with don julia and uh
you know it's a sad day for
all all of us uh blue streak alumni
which you probably didn't know that was
john carroll's um
[Music]
uh name right giant girl blue streaks
did you know that
all right well uh
you know coach schull obviously was was
the first and uh he's a legend that john
carroll obviously a legend in the nfl
and it's uh sad to learn of his passing
today and had a lot to do with uh myself
and probably a lot of the nfl
uh alumni that went to john carroll
about going there
yeah i mean nick casario josh mcdaniels
london fletcher brian and chris polians
the sons of bill pauline tom telesco
greg roman it is amazing to me when you
consider it's a small school like that
and just kind of it kind of happened um
did did that attract you there or did
you not realize at the time you went
there that that this was that there was
going to be this nfl factory coming out
of the blue streets well at the time we
didn't know about that the don chula
effect definitely did and obviously you
know
being a division three athlete there
there wasn't a lot of options and uh you
know john carroll had a great education
but also had the don chula name but back
when i was going to college and uh they
obviously used it as a recruiting tool
and
and i the interesting thing about all of
our past at nfl is i felt like they all
kind of
came in different
different venues
and uh other trivia for those out there
looking to know more about john carroll
university tim russert went there as did
eric carmen
do you know eric carmen's claim to fame
i do not
that you are letting down the blue
streaks eric carmen who sang hungry eyes
from the dirty dancing soundtrack one
hit wonder eric carmen went to john
carroll so now you know now i knew more
about john carroll than you did a little
unknown fact i grew up right down the
street from tim russert in buffalo new
york
i assume you're a bills fan growing up
like like he obviously was he was the
number one bills fan of all time yep
absolutely and bill's fans are they're
passionate just like he was
how
how hard was it for you once you got
into the business to reconcile
the passion that drew you to football
growing up a bills fan and when you're a
true fan of a team you love that team
and you hate every other team there
isn't a hierarchy of well here's my
number one team here's my number two
team here's another no it's the bills
and everybody else can go to hell once
you get into the business isn't it weird
to have to put that down and set that
aside and kind of wall that off and
forget about it and your loyalty is only
to whichever team is employing you at
that time
yeah it was challenging at first and um
especially growing up in buffalo where
there is not you know buffalo is not a
hotbed for college football like down
here in florida or atlanta where i lived
and you you know the allegiance to your
college or your sec teams in the south
is is very great even sometimes greater
than your nfl teams and in buffalo you
know the bills were one-man show besides
the sabers and the bills and uh
those were that that's what we lived for
and growing up and i remember where i
was uh during all four of the uh the
super bowl losses growing up and then
going to college in cleveland and it was
a it was a challenge but
let it be known that uh whenever we play
the bills i still get a lot of texts and
emails and
from some friends and relatives that are
still in buffalo that
they don't care that i work for the
jacksonville jaguars they're still loyal
bills fans what kind of text messages
did you get after beating the bills in
the playoffs a few years ago then well
that was an interesting one that was
probably more challenging for my family
than anything else and i i had i told my
wife i said you have the the no social
media policy for uh for the week leading
up to that game in the week after that
game and uh
you know i think uh she learned the hard
way that that you know the the loyalty
uh may be a little bit bigger for for
the the bills fans than it is for family
yeah uh and and that's the thing of all
teams the bills would be the hardest
ones to segregate and separate that when
you think about the four super bowl
losses which one i assume the first one
is the one that stands out the most
because it was so close is that the one
as a bills fan that you think too that
that just like still has that that
gaping wound
yeah i think the first one obviously
that the game was so close and
and uh for the first time of being in
the super bowl and and being there and
then having a game being
what was a 47-yard field goal wide right
and
i think
that was probably the the most
disappointing one and then they were all
disappointing but uh shouldn't take away
from what those teams accomplished and
that that that was an incredible feat
it really is amazing and i think his
time has gone by there's been a greater
appreciation of getting to the super
bowl suffering the ultimate
disappointment going back to zero and
zero doing it again getting back to the
super bowl losing going back to zero and
zero lather rinse repeat you know there
was a time where
i think that that like the the team that
lost the super bowl was regarded just as
a loser like like get away and i think
that it's different now i really do
think that the team that that doesn't
win the super bowl isn't
remembered in that derisive sense that
it used to be have you sensed to change
in that regard that it's not as big of a
negative to have lost the super bowl
that people appreciate how positive it
is and how hard it is to just get there
well i think that's the point is how
hard it is just to get there um
obviously that the challenging part is
once you're there you realize how hard
it is to get there it makes the loss
even that much more
discouraging because you know that it's
how hard it was to get there and it gets
so close and to lose a game but
obviously the objective is to win it and
um that's that's everyone that goes to
work in the nfl on daily basis that's
what we strive for when you know how
hard it is to get to the brink of it to
have it right there and to have it not
work and then how that can contribute to
everything being thrown off kilder uh
ten point i mean you don't need to be
reminded of this ten point lead the
fourth quarter should have been a 17
point lead if the officials didn't have
their heads up their butts and realized
what miles jack had accomplished ripping
the ball out from dion lewis recovering
it getting up and running for a
touchdown they blew that at least you
got possession of the ball you should
have had the touchdown but it i think it
shows and and you're not the only team
that's gone through this i think when
you get that close
sometimes it is hard to go back to zero
and zero and remember what you did every
box you had to check to get there
there's like a temptation to fast
forward back to the postseason and do it
again and it's not nearly that easy
no it's not and i think i think guys
forget and players forget coaches
i remember that training camp that we
had in 17 and that was a brutal training
camp and coach marone did a heck of a
job getting the team ready and um nobody
expected us to to even have a winning
season let alone get to where we got to
that year and and it's amazing what a
team can accomplish when they play
together as a team and and um when you
have all 11 guys on one side of the ball
competing and doing their job
collectively
far outweighs on any one person or
talent on any team
in a weird sort of way the ingredients
are there to get back to that kind of
mindset this year because i've already
seen
the post draft power rankings that have
the jaguars at number 32 and yes it
pisses you off when you see that but
that can become one of the ingredients
that is used to get the guys to rally
around each other to do everything they
have to do to buckle down and take it
one brick at a time before you end up
standing in front of of a wall where
does your power rankings
i haven't done them yet we haven't done
them yet i do them i have yet to do them
i'll do them later i'll get back to you
at least at 30. but here's the thing
somebody's got to be there somebody's
got to be at the bottom they can't all
be tied at 15 or 16. but i've already
seen somebody else's that had the
jaguars at 32
but but my point is i i think that and
i've seen teams do this where it does
become that rallying cry and it is a way
to get people to forget about anything
but the task at hand and if you can get
the guys pissed off and lathered up it's
good it's positive it's one of the
ingredients in turning a team around
no i think you're right and and right
now it's just noise i mean it is
everybody's got an opinion and and i i
feel like in our team feels like
what we've done in the offseason we may
have gotten rid of some known
commodities but every move that we made
was to put a better product on the field
this year and we feel like we've done
that we've created depth at every
position created competition at all
positions and have a good core of young
players that are coming back that really
produced last year as rookies and second
year guys like dj shark
you know josh allen john taylor had
great rookie years gardner minshew um
you can make the case he was arguably
the best rookie quarterback last year in
many many areas of the game
wins being number one
and uh a good young offensive line so we
feel like there's some pieces in place
here to really go into the season and uh
put our best foot forward and have a
good winning season and hang on a second
are you going to suggest to me that wins
or a quarterback stat is that what
you're saying
well everyone seems to point to that but
uh it does have to happen to have be one
of them
you'll get your fine letter in the mail
so matt casey the coordinating producer
of pft live will find anyone who
describes a quarterback as a winner but
he did have success when he was playing
i'll give you that some would say kyler
murray had a better performance overall
given the statistics that actually you
know determined quarterback play but
minshew was i think special last year
and he resonated with the fan base we
talked to him about that at the super
bowl why is there this nagging sense
that the jaguars organization has a
wandering eye and is looking for an
upgrade over minchu because there is a
palpable sense out there that that
you're willing to explore somebody who
maybe would give you a better chance to
win than mince you if that person is
available sure well i think uh probably
because he was a little bit of an
unknown commodity he was a six-round
pick he didn't have um the name
recognition of being a first-round pick
or
maybe the team didn't invest into him
like other first-round picks that could
get the benefit of the doubt
but he was rookie the week rookie of the
week seven times last year um
so i think that was the most out of any
rookie and um definitely the most on any
rookie quarterback so
um
but wasn't even on the rookie of the
year ballot which was interesting but uh
you know so so i think that's you know i
think that's
how he got here and i think the way
people maybe perceive him because he was
a six-round pick is probably why they
think we have a wandering eye with that
being said we're always about
competition and getting the best people
here so
we do need depth at that position and
bringing in other guys yeah coach marone
recently said that the team will
consider the possibility of bringing in
veteran quarterbacks there aren't many
out there would you be looking for
somebody to come in and be the backup to
garner minshew or is this somebody to
come in push him challenge him and hey
if he ends up being a better option than
mint shoes so be it yeah i think he
always wants somebody there to push and
challenge him also for security and the
bail sleep at night because as as we
know as we learned last year you're 11
or 12 plays away from losing your
starting quarterback for for a large
portion of the time so
um last year when the season and nick
foles got injured
11 plays in the first game of the season
and and that's where kind of the
minchumania kind of took off from there
and
so you always want to have
some type of depth at that position and
somebody to come in and push push your
start gartner does not need anybody to
be
to push him um he is uh incredibly uh
uh
he he's got incredible desire to compete
at the highest level and i think i think
his teammates see that and they feed off
that
what would you say to the people who
would ask the question of why you moved
nick foles you didn't have to he's a
great teammate he's a great backup he'll
come in and do what's asked of him if
and when it's asked of him until that
happens he won't cause any issues won't
cause any problems we'll support the
starter every way he can he was a model
citizen in philadelphia and obviously a
super bowl mvp at the end of the day why
did you decide to move on from him as
the veteran backup or potential starter
uh in jacksonville
yeah that's a great question um i think
with nick's situation is uh
we weren't looking to move them we're
we're looking to keep them and then
there was a handful of teams that
interest in them and we just felt like
if there was value and if we were going
to start and we thought enough of
gardner to name him the starter
or at least compete with nick to be a
star that if we can get
a good value draft pick which we did out
of chicago and get out from underneath
the contract we just felt like it was
the best thing to do for the team
okay um i've gotten many questions from
people as to how to best characterize
the jaguars right now i've heard terms
like rebuilding
reloading retooling tanking right what's
the right word of those that i just
mentioned to describe where the jaguars
currently are what the objective
currently is well i saw something you
wrote the other day that um that
where you said that uh it's not
uh they're not mutually exclusive we're
kind of we can still build this thing
and compete at a high level and and let
the chips fall where they may and i
think what we did was we we cleaned up
the salary cap we're in a great working
situation with the salary cap not only
this year but next year
and um also felt like that we've gotten
better from the six and ten team that we
had last year or the 511 team although
there were a lot of household names that
that people recognized nationally
the product on the field wasn't where it
needed to be so i would say competing i
would say competing and and building for
something that uh
that can compete this year you got the
second defensive back off the board in
this year's draft with cj henderson at
number nine tell me what attracted you
to him in that spot well his rare
athleticism and his speed and his length
uh he's a perfect fit for our scheme
he's got excellent ball skills and uh he
competes at a high level against some of
the best receivers in the
college football
and then at number 20 another first
round pick for the jaguars the one that
came as part of the jaylen ramsey trade
kayla von chason one of my favorite
prospects this year i was stunned he was
still there at number 20. how surprised
were you that he made it through 19
picks and was still available to be
taken by you in that spot we were
surprised and he was one of my favorite
throughout the whole uh season and i
remember watching him in early october
and asking our scouts about him and
they're like well he's a redshirt
sophomore he's not going to come out i'm
like this guy's coming out and he's
going to be a top 10 pick and
sure enough he did come out he wasn't a
top 10 pick was close though and uh at
the end of the day he's he's a guy that
everything that we want he's high
character tough competitive ultimate
team guy can play to run and rush the
passer and uh we feel like that he has a
tremendous developmental upside you know
we're at the scouting combine and
because of the changes to the schedule
this year we had the opportunity to talk
to between 25 and 30 of the prospects
he's the one that stood out to me he's
got a charisma that that exudes
confidence but it's not in a brash
abrasive way it's just very matter of
fact this is who i am this is what i'm
gonna do
and to me look that it may not it may
not become
the core of a leadership component right
away but that's the kind of guy that i
think you want at the heart of your
locker room getting other guys to think
the same way and act the same way
absolutely and we have a guy like that
and josh allen right now that we took
last year with the with the seventh pick
in the draft and uh to have those two
guys on on the opposite edges of each
other
and uh feel like that that's going to be
a really good core for us moving forward
you know it was announced today there
won't be any international games in 2020
that means two home games you were going
to play in london will now be played in
jacksonville i look i i know that that's
something the organization wanted to do
but from your perspective trying to win
football games trying to have continuity
it's got to be easier to not have to go
over to london and stay there for more
than a week to play back-to-back games
yeah obviously we'd like to play in
front of our fans here in jacksonville
and um and have the home field advantage
we really appreciate our fans in london
and actually the game the last seven
years has has really been a a good thing
for not only the city of jackson but but
also for our team and to be able to go
over there for a week a year and have
our team bond and grow together has been
a good thing we've had success on the
field over there
we'll miss our fans over there but we're
eagerly and overly excited to be able to
have two home games here in front of our
home fans and and we know they'll show
up
how close did you come to finding a
trade partner for london fournette
uh you know uh to be honest with you
there was just some minor discussions
about that but not nothing substantial
throughout the draft or even prior to
the draft is he still available or is
the mindset at this point we go forward
with leonard on the team i think the
mindset is we're going to go forward
with london on team i had a good
conversation with him on friday i know
coach morrow's had some discussions with
him um he seems to be in great shape and
and great
mental uh frame of mind and we feel like
that he'll he'll have a great season
this year coach marone spoke with mike
tarico a couple of weeks ago and talked
about the reality that
leonard's comments about getting cam
newton on the team that's something that
leonard and gardner are going to have to
work out among themselves
when you have a team that's not going to
be getting together until who knows when
is it important to get that worked out
has it been worked out have they had to
your knowledge a conversation where
they're on the same page moving forward
i'm sure they'll be on the same page
both are professional guys and uh and
i'm sure uh a lot of it probably was
taken out of context from my
understanding um gartner is a tremendous
leader and i think leonard will will do
his best and putting his best foot
forward so i don't not to my knowledge i
don't know what's been taking place but
uh i'm sure it won't be an issue dave i
love you but i can't let you get away
with taken out of context the guy came
out and said he wants cam newton on the
team
well
i'm sure he'd probably like a lot of
people on the team
but um it's not fantasy football yeah
sure um
so uh
you know i look at your quarterback
depth chart and we talked earlier about
the guys who are available and i never
know where the line is for tampering
andy dalton's now under contract with
the cowboys can you comment whether or
not on on whether you tried to get him
we did have some discussions with his uh
agent and uh with him
and i guess i'll leave it at that
um well
i'll leave it at this i gotta let you
get back to your day i gotta wish you a
happy anniversary 18 years of wedded
bliss and i appreciate you giving us so
much of your time on a day when your
wife would otherwise expect to see you
but i would guess
that given the amount of time you've
been home
for the past seven weeks
your wife is fine with a break from time
to time of having to deal with you i've
been working at home for 11 years and my
wife loves it when i get out of her hair
for a little bit
she is and she she gives me the subtle
questions so when are the nfl's going to
open up their offices again
so i i get that question periodically
well hey uh congratulations on all
you've done in jacksonville we're
rooting for you to get it turned around
this year you got some great young
players it's gonna be fun to see how it
all falls together dave thanks as always
for some of your time and we'll talk to
you soon thanks mike have a great week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports